A few weeks ago I began taking black sand blood, so black sand blood is a capsule supplement that has
granola and black sand and some other things in it. Per your recommendation three times a day,
about 10 days after the first dose also took water edema and had dead parasites in it. This caused me to
ask some questions. First, should I take a medisol for three days in addition to blood root to kill
any parasites? Or will the blood root kill the parasites alone? So the parasites are not
giving you black sand blood root to kill parasites. So I do not, I have never recommended
sand blood root for the purpose of killing parasites. I recommended the black sand blood root for
the purpose of helping your body kill cancer cells. So that is the purpose of now it is half
things in there that can help kill parasites. Sure. Can you take fed medisol with black sand blood root?
Yes, you can. If you're not currently taking fed medisol, should you take it just because
you saw the parasites? I wouldn't know. If that's part of your protocol that I would stay on it and
follow your protocol. Is there a conflict of taking fed medisol and black sand blood root at the same
time? No. And should I stop taking any other supplements before taking fed medisol? No. So you can take
fed medisol with all your other supplements as well.